we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P I I don't I
don't want to pick on the person that
left this voicemail but it's an example
of a problem I've said a lot of people
haven't read the molar report take a
listen to this voicemail okay how about
a David Pakman my name is Raquel I'll
hang up on and a longtime listener I am
curious if there's any this probably
sentiment a lot of people are curious
about how does one get access to the
molar report can you go through the
Freedom of Information Act and request
for it this is something that you can
get in if you go to the library they can
access it for you I'm not sure how they
get that so I'm wanting to read it and
I'm just curious how average person
would get ahold yeah listen I I'm not
trying to I'm not making fun of anyone
I'm not picking on you this is a massive
problem in society okay the the molar
report has been out everywhere on the
internet for four weeks at this point
you just go to Google you type in molar
report full-text there will be hundreds
of results websites that have uploaded
it it's it's it's widely available the
Department of Justice released it so
I've talked about we have a problem in
this country where a lot of people
haven't actually read the report they're
going by what Barr said or whatever it's
also this is not the only message I've
gotten like this from people who they
don't know they they're under the
impression I'm struggling for words here
because I want to I want to be
respectful and polite people are trying
to figure out well where can I even find
this thing you just google it it's it
comes up right right away okay I'm
feeling a little depressed I'm not gonna
lie after that but let's read this thing
it's widely available on the bonus show
today I've got a big announcement very
very big announcement get the bonus show
become a member I think everybody about
the hey tree it's will like this
announcement speak to you then